since there's uh there's artists there's
filmmakers and so on
and you're all of those
uh on top of being a great athlete I
don't know I'll just stop the running
joke at this point uh but is there have
you uh thought about
um just just in general like we've
offline talked about microphones and
like all the different ways to film
space launch uh for the rocket launches
uh have you thought about the different
options of like how to capture
how to capture this uh have you have the
team have been like brainstorming and
thinking about this do you anticipate it
being super challenging because there's
so many opportunities to sort of think
of how to do this so one of the fun
things to remember is that Starship is
huge like its internal volume is uh the
pressurized volume on Starship is is
bigger than a 747s pressurized volume
and it can take a hundred metric tons to
anywhere with enough refueling 100 so we
have in theory very little mass and
volume constraints unlike prior all
other space flight missions ever you you
think you're counting you know grams
down to you know and just really can't
risk you know you have very defined
parameters on on what you cannot do
we're going to likely have the luxury of
being able to film and capture this in a
way that's just never been done before
you know we won't be inhibited by mass
and volume constraints like prior yeah
so
all that said and done I'm hoping that
we'll be able to just arm ourselves to
the teeth with the absolute best cameras
and Equipment possible backups on
backups and
you know on pre-wire you know like
pre-rig things Starship is going to be a
transportation system and it has you
know it's being built from the ground up
there's no reason why they can't
put infrastructure in for cameras that
are just housed in the vehicle you know
um these are talks that I'm excited to
have because I really ideally one of the
things I'd love to do I'm going to be
pushing really hard to actually try live
streaming
from inside during the launch
during the launch live stream from the
inside that would be incredible wouldn't
that be
it's possible to pull off that's really
really incredible now there is the magic
to the live stream because like that's
real that's right there that would the
world would tune in that would be truly
inspiring yes to me that's one of those
things a lot of people ask why they
aren't doing it of course NASA and other
individuals have their reasons of why
not you know there's obviously some
technical hurdles but now with starlink
and other capabilities there's
less hurdles there's obviously some
transparency reasons why you know on
safety reasons why it might not be a
great idea to live stream a risky rocket
launch you know the Challenger I think
put a pretty bad
tasting our mouth as far as publicizing
an event and having every student in the
United States tune in to you know a
tragedy but
um that's something I'm pushing for
really hard just because I think it
could be magical I think it could really
connect with people in a way that hasn't
been done before